I'm Jillian Peterson I'm a criminologist
and former investigator let's answer
some questions from the internet this is
true crime
[Music]
support at becoming Jill asks isn't the
spouse always the first suspect when it
comes to women being murdered yes 35 to
50% of them are murdered by either a
current spouse or partner or a former
spouse or partner so if you can rule out
things like a robbery gone back a drug
deal gone bad a fight that escalated
gang violence if you can rule all those
things out definitely your next most
likely suspect is going to be the spouse
at Joi shei asked did you know that 1%
of cold cases are solved our current
clearance rate for murder in this
country is only about 50% if you commit
a murder it's kind of flip of the coin
whether or not you get arrested for it
our clearance weights are way down I
think it has to do with we've seen such
an increase in homicide the last few
years and with that we've had a decrease
just in the number of police officers we
have it's a lot more than 1% of cases
that are unsolved at brother grimbo
asked did Jack the Ripper exist or was
Victorian England just kind of stabby
Jack the river did exist committed a
series of really violent gruesome
murders so as an example just to show
what it was like during that period of
time this is a news report from 1888 I
think it really knows that Victorian in
England was a rather stabby place during
this period of time there's actually
another serial killer who was operating
at the time named Thomas cream he was
convicted of poisoning nine or 10 people
during the exact same period of time
during his execution his final words are
rumored to be I am Jack dot dot dot
although he was actually in prison at
the time of some of the murder so it
really couldn't have been him and we
still don't know exactly who Jack the
Ripper is at MSL Simpson as my sister
just sent me a message to say that she
listened to a podcast and is going off
to try to solve a murder who needs the
police yes this is a thing where
individuals listen to podcasts and they
think I can solve this it's known as
citizen sluth the January 6th riots a
lot of the individuals who ended up
being criminally charged or identified
by cian sluth on social media trying to
identify them in the case of the Gabby
petito murder who was killed by Brian
laundry her fiance she was missing for a
long period of time it was really a
group of young people on Tik Tok that
started uploading videos of the park
where she went missing the van was
spotted and they were really able to
locate her body and isolate where she
was located however if you talk to most
police officers they will say they do
not like this movement of Citizen SLO
that often times they can go down rabbit
holes and end up accusing people who are
truly innocent and that can really
destroy lives at nurman man's 463 302
ask why do serial killers kill I want to
study their brains so badly generally we
can say there's three big categories one
being power and control I think one
example of a power and control serial
killer might be somebody like the Zodiac
Killer who was attacking primarily young
couples it was really about murdering
people who were kind of in the prime of
their life one is a sexual motivation
sexual fantasy the sexual fantasy
category story is often people who are
sexually aroused by violence or sexually
aroused by having sex with bodies after
they've killed them one example of
somebody motivated by sexual fantasy
would be Ted Bundy the third category
would be a serial killer motivated by
hallucinations good example of that
would be like the Son of Sam killer who
was motivated by delusions there has
been some studies of mostly murderers
brains we do see some differences
particular particularly in an area
called the amydala which is a part of
the brain that controls things like fear
and aggression it's hard to say that
that's causal it's the brain that causes
the behavior the behavior that causes
changes in the brain but there does seem
to be something there in some of these
early studies at code Smith asks why
have murders increased during the coid
19 pandemic we saw a massive spike in
homicide during coid 19 the biggest year
on-year increase in homicide we've ever
seen since we started tracking this it
was about a third increase or a 30% jump
other forms of crime went down but
homicide specifically spiked could be
because people weren't working there was
Financial strain there was stress
there's also this thing that happened
where George Floyd was murdered a lot of
cities started pulling back their
policing that's sometimes referred to as
de policing so it's really hard to pull
apart which of these factors was the
main driver it was likely all of it at
once at leap Perez Ray asks is # the
best at murder in the whole world we are
a standout when it comes to murder um if
you look at other countries similar to
ours so places in Europe Canada
Australia most countries are under one
homicide per 100,000 residents the
United States is at 4.38 to we aren't
the worst in the entire world there are
other countries per capita in Latin
America who do have a higher rate than
places like
Honduras Mexico Jamaica but when it
comes to sort of similarly developed
countries America really stands out at
Trisha mckuin 13 ask could a psychopath
grow through life without giving any
sign or will there always be something
that is a giveaway some we trait yes you
can go through life and not know that
someone is a psychopath you see high
rates of psychopathy in Industries like
the entertainment industry law enforce
forcement law politics being a serial
killer being violent committing crime is
actually not one of the symptoms it's
what we tend to think of when we think
of psychopaths there really isn't
anything like killing animals or setting
fires that's going to be a tell if I was
going to name one thing that might be a
giveaway it would be a trouble reading
other people's emotions and maybe
mimicking back emotions without really
feeling those emotions at thar yardi
says okay can someone please tell me the
difference between a sociopath and a
psychopath please there's really no
clear distinction sociopath is a word
that was used more in the 80s and the
90s it's used less today it's used maybe
by the media and in pop culture but as
the criminology field we've really moved
towards psychopathy being the thing that
we look for that we can Define
clinically that we know how to test for
and so the field had just gone more in
the direction of using psychopath as
opposed to sociopath at David 7598 3862
asks so since the early 90s why have gun
murder rate gone down while the number
of guns has significantly increased I
might disagree on this one our murder
rate in the 90s was extremely high then
we did see a big dip in the 2210 so it
was sort of high in the 90s it went down
and then the last five years and
particularly last two years we've really
seen it spark back up again during that
period of time gun ownership increased
in this country over time particularly
the last couple of years so we now have
more guns than people in this country
about 120 Americans are killed by guns
every day that would include homicides
suicides accidents police shootings but
about 120 people total at the flying
nipple ask terrifying I wonder how many
unexplained missing persons there are
it's about half a million people a year
go missing that is down from maybe a
million a year back in the '90s but
estimates are about 90% of them are
found most of them are young people
running away from home but 10% of that
half million missing still leaves 50,000
people who are missing and unaccounted
for every year CC1 ask real question
what percentage of mass Shooters are
male the answer is 98% of mass Shooters
are male at truth or dare ask my
question about these Mass Shooters is
this why schools whether it's an
elementary middle or high school what
attracts you to kill children about
9919 2% of them are actually students at
that school so this is people targeting
their own school or they might be former
students but most likely they're current
students they're 15 16 years old my own
research shows that these perpetrators
come from homes with lots of violence
and abuse they tend to study other
perpetrators who are like them and feel
like they're a part of them and then
they target their own school because
that's where they have the grievance
against those are the people that they
blame for their misery school shootings
are designed to be final acts so
perpetrators go in knowing they're not
going to come out of it and in fact they
want to be known for this they're
craving that notoriety they want their
name in the history books at snack time
ask Murdoch murders is such a crazy
series on Netflix like how in the world
did these people get away with all of
this Alex Murdoch has been convicted of
killing his wife and his child and
there's also other murders that he may
or may not be guilty of including a
housekeeper I think this is a good
example of how in these small
communities it can be really hard to
have an independent criminal
investigation especially if somebody who
has a lot of status and Power in the
town and it's really important that
who's ever investigating a crime has
absolutely no relationship with any of
the suspects because once that starts
getting mixed you see mistakes getting
made and it could be a conscious bias
but often times it's just unconscious
because of the preconceived notions that
you have about people at book marquinn
asked do you not worry that all the
criminology television programs that are
on these days that the criminals will
learn from it and avoid detection we've
seen television programs having an
effect on the everyday public we refer
to this as the CSI effect in the
criminal justice system where people
sitting on juries have this expectation
that they'll be you know carpet fiber
from some foreign place that will help
them identify the body and if that
doesn't exist then they're more likely
to acquit there's been one study that
looked at this and they did not find a
similar CSI effect for criminals it did
not seem like they were learning from
these programs and getting smarter at
committing crimes likely because a lot
of crime is maybe impulsive and not that
well planned out so far we are not
seeing that next question who was
America's most prolific serial killer
was named Samuel little he conf Fess to
killing over 90 people this is a series
of mug shots of Samuel little he was
arrested by the police for various
crimes but it was never put together
that he was the one murdering all of
these women he committed murder from
about 1970 until 2005 his victims tended
to be sex workers women addicted to
drugs women living on the streets and
his method was he tended to strangle
these women it wasn't in until they
eventually pulled Samuel Little's DNA
that they were able to go back and
connect him to all these previous crimes
and then he confessed all of them he can
be connected to for sure 50 or 60 or so
of them but they think that all 90 of
his confessions are legit puppet combo
asked what kind of job would a serial
killer have and if we look at patterns
in the data there are some jobs that
emerge as maybe over represented things
like mechanics machinists you see a
number number of truck drivers and
police officers where it's maybe easier
to get away with the crime the data on
serial killers Is Not Great generally
across the board just because there's so
few of them and it's hard to study at
tabas asks in light of the recent case
of the nurse are female serial killers
more likely to be in caring professions
than not there's not that many female
serial killers but of them there have
been quite a few nurses a study recently
published that looked at 16 different
nurs is who had committed serial murder
across the globe and across centuries
and they did find that it tended to be
poisoning and it tended to be go
undetected for a long period of time
because of the profession that they had
this recent case I believe is referring
to the British nurse who was just
sentenced for killing seven newborn
babies another example of a serial
killer nurse is Kristen Gilbert who is
an American nurse who was convicted of
murdering four of her patients that were
in her care I would not extend that to
other caring professions I don't think
there's a lot of Social Work serial
killers but certainly when it comes to
nurses we see it at Pat doc five ask
what age do serial killers typically
start killing people it's actually older
than other forms of violence when it
comes to serial killing they start mid
to late 20s so it tends to be a bit of a
later onset at dther 715 asked two
questions who was the Zodiac Killer and
why was it Ted Cruz ever caught there's
a lot of people who have been accused of
being the Zodiac Killer over time Ted
Cruz is not one of them the Zodiac
Killer committed a series of murders in
Northern California in the 1960s at
least five that they know of there may
have been more this is a composite
sketch of what they think the Zodiac
Killer looked like based on a couple of
the victims who actually survived there
was one suspect that was named Arthur
Lee Allen was a school teacher teacher
but there was never enough evidence to
actually link him to the crimes it was
all circumstantial he did several years
in prison for molesting children and
then died in the early 90s so nobody was
ever convicted of these crimes there was
a number of unique things about the
Zodiac Killer he sent letters that he
demanded be printed in the newspaper he
created these mathematical ciphers which
were like these coded puzzles that he
wanted people to spend time on trying to
unravel one was was cracked about a week
after it was published two are still
unsolved and one was actually only
cracked a few years ago 60 years after
the crime a team of mathematicians
cracked it the ciphers didn't give away
his identity they basically just said I
like killing all my victims will become
my slaves and an afterlife it didn't
give any additional Clues he was
interested in making the public a part
of these murders drawing people in
forcing them to sort of play with these
codes that he was publishing at big ball
179335 asks why do serial killers in
prison get tons of marriage proposals
from women this is a phenomenon I have
worked on capital murder cases with
people facing the death penalty and the
more media coverage the case got the
more letters those individuals would
receive I think women who write these
letters are romantically drawn towards
this very dangerous person who has done
these scary dangerous things I don't
think these women are looking to
themselves to get harmed but they are
drawn to the fact that this person is
capable of doing that level of harm at
Colleen Ben asked does it seem like
family annihilators are happening more
often there was a spike of family
annihilations in 2019 where we saw
record levels and then it's come back
town I think we hear about them more
often through media and through social
media and our exposure so it can feel
like they're happening more often family
Annihilation is when a man kills
typically his wife his children and then
usually himself all in one act we have
about to 10 to 20 of those per year
Family annihilations unfortunately are
always something that has happened in
history family annihilators are
typically men they're a bit older 40s
maybe 50s Elementary School aged
children they tend to have a history of
domestic violence and suicidality they
are suicides in addition to being
homicides but they're these kind of
angry suicides where it's I'm not just
going to kill myself I'm going to make
sure my wife and children come with me
so they don't get to exist without me so
there's a level of I think control that
comes with committing that sort of
violence at Dana blankenhorn asked why
did Jeffrey dmer eat people he was a
serial killer who after he had killed
someone he would take apart their bodies
body parts were found in the freezer in
various states of Decay and then he
would actually admitted to eating their
bodies Jeffrey dmer has been asked about
this on a few different occasions and I
think there's one theory that this is
really about complete dominance and
control over your victims you can't be
more dominant over something than to
consume it then there's been some recent
reports lately that said it was maybe
more about actually connecting with the
victims that he was very lonely and
consuming his victims allowed him to
kind of be a part of those victims at ml
tanova asks if Ted Bundy were killing in
this gen he wouldn't make it too far
everyone has phones that have emergency
features drones and satellites could
track him cars are traceable today's
forensics and DNA tracing is incredible
Etc serial killing really peaked in the
70s 80s and early 90s then we've seen
just this massive fall where there are
now very few serial killers today that's
because of advances in all sorts of
Technology primarily DNA also we've just
changed our Behavior not a lot of people
are going going hitchhiking these days
and getting in cars of strangers and if
you did you'd certainly text someone to
say you were there so I agree that Ted
Bundy would not get away with serial
killing these days at metal dad asks who
else thinks missing hikers isn't Just A
Series of Unfortunate accidents most of
those cases are people who fall or
there's accidents but a number of people
are not recovered and there is actually
a number of serial killers of murders
where it took place while somebody was
hiking it makes me think of the Gabby
petito murder who was killed by her
fiance Brian laundry when they were out
hiking and this makes me think about
this theory of crime it's called routine
activities and it's where you have a
motivated offender a suitable Target and
then a lack of capable Guardianship and
so hiking is kind of your perfect
example of a total lack of guardianship
there's nobody around for Miles there's
no cameras often time there's no cell
coverage you can easily dispose of a
body you can make it look like an a in
those are all the questions for today
those were some great questions thanks
so much for watching True Crime
[Music]
support